on this friday night the johnson and
johnson jab
now approved in canada what sets it
apart from the three other approved
vaccines
and the injection of optimism it brings
your turn
is coming fearing for their lives
workers are saying
i am frightened to go back to work
amplifying calls to prioritize and
immunize people
who cannot work from home what's up with
this
the explanation behind what appears to
be a floating
ship and wayne gretzky says his dad
was truly the great one i can help one
person to have a second chance of life
it's a wonderful feeling
the legacy of walter gretzky on and off
the ice
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
the timelines for covid 19 vaccinations
in this country are moving up
after the approval of a fourth vaccine
with millions more doses now expected
sooner than originally thought
the provinces are able to accelerate and
expand their rollouts
we are expecting far more doses
by september than there are canadians
so we have reasons to be optimistic
we're going to be able to move things
forward the vaccine approved today is
from johnson and johnson it only
requires
one dose and can be stored in normal
refrigerators for up to three months
making it easier to distribute
health canada says it is both safe and
effective and adds to the arsenal of the
three other approved vaccines from
pfizer biontech
moderna and oxford astrazeneca it means
the provinces are revising their
timelines now each province
is handling it a little bit differently
ontario and bc now say they hope to get
at least one dose to everyone who wants
one by
early this summer and age won't be the
only criteria
people with underlying health conditions
and essential workers those who can't
work from home
are going to move up in the queue ikela
couture has more
in our top story tonight on the
increasingly optimistic
timeline there is light at the end of
the tunnel
and i'm feeling real positive this week
ontario premier doug ford has reason to
be optimistic
the retired general in charge of his
province's vaccine rollout
laid out a new timeline for mass
vaccination
our aim would be is to allow the
province of ontario to have a first
needle in the arm of every eligible
person
who wants it by the first day of summer
manitoba is being even more ambitious
saying if supplies
are there every adult could get their
first dose of the vaccine
by may 18th newfoundland and labrador
also announced the first
oxford astrazeneca vaccines will be
given to first responders
and frontline essential workers it all
comes as canada is set to receive
a deluge of doses canada is
on track to receive at least 36.5
million doses of vaccines
by the end of june and a cumulative
total
of a hundred and seventeen point nine
million doses
of vaccines by the end of september
3.5 million doses of the pfizer biotech
vaccine are being delivered
sooner than expected it's perhaps why
bc's top
doctor made this bold prediction maybe
i'm
too optimistic but we're going to be in
our post-pandemic world by this summer
if things continue to go the way that we
want them to the federal government is
sticking to its timeline to have every
canadian who wants a shot
vaccinated by september cautioning
supply
issues that we saw from pfizer earlier
this year
could happen again that's why canada
secured a suite of shots
but there's also concern that could
encourage vaccine
shopping some people might try to
compare efficacy rates
the johnson and johnson vaccine's
efficacy is 66
but those on the front lines point out
they all do the job
they all protect against infection
hospitalization
death and quite frankly i'd be happy
with any one of those if it came my way
and there is a fifth on the way the
novovax vaccine
is still in phase three clinical trials
so health canada doesn't expect
it'll be approved for at least a few
weeks or even
months donna right michael couture in
ottawa thanks
there is a lot of ground to cover before
the provinces reach their new goals over
the past five days
about 70 000 vaccine doses have been
administered on average
per day so far just over 1.6 million
canadians have received at least
one dose and that works out to about
four point three percent of the
population
in manitoba efforts are now underway to
get doses to remote communities the
government there says vaccination
clinics will launch in the next few
weeks
the priority will be communities at risk
of floods and fires
this will ensure that communities most
at risk
do not see their spring and summer
hazards compounded
by the pandemic and leaving them more at
risk from potential emergency
situations or evacuations
once those vaccines are complete the
manitoba government says it will move on
to
the first nations that have experienced
the worst outbreaks
in ontario the last three covet hot
spots under strict stay-at-home orders
will see restrictions ease next week
starting on monday toronto and the
neighboring peel region will be in the
gray
lockdown category but the stay-at-home
order will be lifted
that will allow some businesses to open
their doors for the first time since
november
though gyms personal care services and
indoor restaurant dining will
stay closed the north bay perry sound
district will return to
red the second most restrictive level
health officials say cases
are still high there but progress is
being made
and health officials in new brunswick
say all residents who want to be
vaccinated will be able to get their
shot
before the end of june that province is
also easing restrictions because of a
steady downward trend in infections
starting monday the entire province is
shifting to the less restrictive
yellow level it means residents can
expand their bubbles
dine out at restaurants and cross
regional zones
to play team sports well alberta isn't
there yet but
with cases and hospitalizations
declining that province moved into step
two of its reopening plan this week
and today marks one year since the first
case of covid19 was reported in alberta
since then more than 134 000 albertans
have tested positive
and many of them work in meat plants the
ali male pork plant
reopened this week after an outbreak
infected more than 500 workers
three of them died several more are
still in icu
and unvaccinated employees are anxious
about going back to work
as heather urex west explains labor
leaders and the industry say it's time
they were given vaccine priority
workers at ali mill's pork processing
plant are back at work
two weeks after the industry's deadliest
outbreak of covet 19
shut the facility down i feel bad for
the guys who work there
most of them are my friends workers are
saying
it is so sad to go back to work i am
frightened to go back to work
at least six alberta meat processing
plant workers have died from kova 19
over the last year 51 year old benito
quesada
and 67 year old hip buoy worked for
cargill in high river
fifty-year-old henry de leon and
thirty-five-year-old darwin deloque
worked at ali mel
two other workers have not been
identified one worked at alimel
the other for jbs in brooks it's
important for albertans to understand
this
there have been outbreaks in meat
packing plants
all over the country throughout this
cove 19 pandemic
it is only in alberta where there have
been
tragic fatalities there has been at
least one other covid19 related death
involving a meat processing facility
outside of alberta
but the outbreaks in this province have
been among the country's biggest and
most deadly and we don't really know yet
why
what we do know is that a year into this
pandemic workers in these facilities
continue to face incredible risk if you
look at the entire supply chain i would
say the most vulnerable workers
are right in the middle in processing
because things are tight
things are intense working conditions
aren't great for people but they are
great for a virus
it's why the industry is calling on
provinces to prioritize
these workers in the next phases of the
covet 19 vaccine rollout
given the proximity of how the workers
operate in the facilities
you know they're just more susceptible
to transmission of covate
bc and ontario list essential workers in
phase
three a population not scheduled for
vaccination
until late spring or summer alberta's
plan so far does not prioritize
essential workers
but the province says they could receive
vaccine in the summer
if there's adequate supply and so
workers here
and at meat processing facilities across
the country will wait
doing what they can to be safe but
knowing
after losing beloved co-workers like
darwin de loke
that safety cannot be guaranteed heather
urex west global news calgary
each province has its own strategy and
timeline for vaccinations and those are
being revised now as more vaccines
arrive
there is not always agreement over which
groups should get priority
as amanda gellawiki reports some doctors
in quebec want people with serious
illnesses such as cancer
bumped up the list deborah bridgman
suffers from metastatic breast cancer
receiving regular chemotherapy she's
terrified of contracting kovid
i've been fighting cancer for 27 years
now
and i'll be damned if i'm going to die
from covid she's
desperate for the vaccine but at 57
years old
she's low on quebec's vaccination
priority list
despite facing stage four cancer i think
it's sad that they
have us such on a low priority list
because
a lot of patients that do contract covid
they have to stop treatments and the
treatments are what keep us
alive with quebec's mass vaccination
plan well underway
a growing chorus of doctors is raising
concerns about the province's
vaccination strategy
unfortunately the government has decided
that
priority will be just based on age
rather than
a condition the province has a list of
10 categories for vaccination
people with cancer and other serious
illnesses under 60 years old
ranked number eight on the list the main
risk factor we have to remember
is age for example a person 70 to 79
years of age is nearly a hundred times
more at risk to die
if they get covered each canadian
province has its own vaccine priority
list
bc allows people 16 to 69 to get
vaccinated at the same time as people in
their 70s
if they are clinically vulnerable
ontario is including people with high
risk or chronic conditions in phase two
of their vaccination rollout
and alberta has prioritized people with
underlying health conditions
over people aged 50 to 64. quebec's
association of oncologists is pressuring
the government to modify its list
this is very urgent because these
patients
are being at risk of developing
infection
and complications of that infection are
putting
the whole health care system at risk of
getting saturated once more
quebec's immunization committee says
it's reviewing its current
recommendations
it says it will release new guidelines
in a few weeks
amanda jeliwicki global news montreal
brazil's dire covid situation coming up
is it a warning to the world plus great
apes making
medical history
pope francis is in iraq his first
international trip since the pandemic
began and the first papal visit to that
country
he's called for an end to violence in
extremism and hopes to revive iraq's
ancient and dwindling christian
community
he'll also meet iraq's most revered shia
muslim cleric
security and covid are two big risks
of his visit in brazil there has been a
staggering number of new coveted cases
and the death toll
has reached record levels hospitals
across brazil are overwhelmed
it's being driven in part by a more
transmissible variant
brazil's president has told people not
to be sissies
but as crystal gamansing explains what's
happening there could be a warning
to the rest of the world they spend
hours draped head to toe
in white but for many health care
workers in brazil
their world is dark it's horrifying
to say the least when i arrived here in
mid-january i've seen a hospital that
normally had 20 beds only
or a small small facility and they had
at
this point almost 50 patients all of
them of it
and many of them died all the time fabio
biokini is the manaus field coordinator
for doctors without borders
in the first wave so many in the region
were sick it was believed more than half
of the population
had immunity then
re-infections occurred the p1 variant
might be the cause a preliminary
research paper suggests
p1 can be between 1.4 and 2.2 times
more transmissible than local non-p1
lineages
and can evade 25 to 61 percent of
protective
immunity elicited by previous infection
so it's a very scary situation
it's even more scary because you don't
have a conclusion yet
with a virus surging across brazil and
numerous hospitals on the brink of
collapse
this professor who studies disease
projection says
everyone is at risk we need to control
this virus as soon as possible
otherwise we will keep having new
variants that's what viruses do they
mutate all the time
and we risk having a mutation that will
be even
make the vaccine even less effective
vaccines are
still seen as the best route out of the
pandemic
the rollout in brazil has been slow
less than three and a half percent of
the population has received a single
dose
crystal glancing global news london
it's not only humans who are getting
vaccinated nine great apes at the san
diego zoo have been given an
experimental covid19 vaccine
four orangutans and five bonobos got the
shot earlier this year
it happened soon after a troop of
gorillas at the zoo became infected with
the virus
three more bonobos and a gorilla are
expected to get vaccinated soon
around the world several animals
including tigers and mink have tested
positive
for covid19 rolling on the red planet
next another first for nasa's
perseverance
that is perseverance getting ready to
roll along the red planet the nasa rover
has completed its first official spin on
the surface of mars
the test drive was captured through the
robot's electronic eyes
the excursion was short just to roll
forward and a turn
it's part of a crucial series of checks
before perseverance begins to search for
clues mars could have supported life
in the ancient past a man walking along
the coast of cornwall
england couldn't quite believe what he
saw on the horizon so
he took a picture it appears to be a
huge tanker ship hovering above the
water
in fact it is an optical illusion known
as a looming superior mirage it's more
common in the arctic
and is caused by a meteorological
phenomenon called a temperature
inversion when warm air sits on top of a
band of colder air and
light is refracted in a way that creates
an illusion that objects
are floating prince philip has moved
again but
not back home buckingham palace says the
duke of edinburgh has been transferred
from a london cardiac center to king
edward vii
hospital that's where he was first
admitted nearly three weeks ago
the 99 year old is recovering from an
infection and a procedure for a
pre-existing heart condition
the gretzky family loses their patriarch
next remembering canada's
hockey dad
a trailblazing canadian environmental
conservationist is being mourned tonight
david schindler from the university of
alberta was an expert on freshwater
lakes and
co-founded the experimental lakes area
in ontario his work was instrumental in
changing public policy and
led to restrictions on acid emissions
chemicals and detergent and
contamination
from the oil sands tributes are pouring
in one colleague wrote he was a
tremendous scientist especially
freshwater ecology
and a tireless advocate for conservation
who spoke truth
to power david schindler lived in
briscoe bc with his wife
he died yesterday at the age of 80.
and the world learned of the death of
another great canadian
from his son wayne gretzky wayne tweeted
that his father walter was the reason i
fell in love with the game of hockey
he inspired me to be the best i could be
not just in the game of hockey
but in life walter gretzky died
yesterday at the age of 82
still living in the brantford ontario
home where he raised his five kids
wayne says he was their team captain
that walter
was truly the great one and as eric
sorenson reports
anyone who loved hockey couldn't help
but love him
too this is the father most canadians
knew the proud dad watching his boy play
hockey
but this is the walter gretzky that said
much more about the man himself via
l-e-a-h away from the limelight he would
give his time to anyone he could make
just a little happier could i get your
autograph right now please
and it's kind of like what they hear
they can't get the first w
everybody settles for the second w
that's me wayne walder
for walter gretzky putting a rink in the
backyard was the easy part for a son who
wanted to be on the ice all the time
millions of parents raised their kids to
play hockey but only one
dad and mom raised the one and only my
mom and dad were
my they're the reason that i made the
nhl wayne gretzky told in depth with
graham benzinger that his dad
instilled in him something more than
hockey the importance of always doing
the best he could
he said for whatever reason the good
lord has chosen you
and each and every time you play people
want to see
what the fuss and what everything is all
about and you can't afford not to be
ready
to play the best you can play wayne
gretzky not only became the best hockey
player
in the world he was humble and
hard-working like his dad
and so the most famous hockey dad in the
world felt an obligation too
go get a helmet he gave his time to kids
hockey and he raised millions of dollars
for charities
including the canadian national
institute for the blind and his family's
own foundation
i can help one person just one person
to have a second chance of life like i
have walter gretzky overcame a brain
aneurysm and fought parkinson's disease
for years
so he could visit hospitals and help
others in need walter told biographer
fred anderton
a friend of 40 years how much it meant
to him it just all makes me cry every
time you think of it
some of them have absolutely nothing and
they're so thankful
i think for walter the essence of
living was giving he's probably the most
genuine human being you could
ever hope to meet in edmonton home to so
many gretzky stanley cups the oilers are
remembering walter
it's a very sad day for the hockey world
to
lose kind of hockey's dad almost in
brantford ontario the gretzky name is
everywhere
walter gretzky is part of a legacy from
his hometown to every corner of the
country
walt was a great father and i wish i
could have been as good a father as him
this is a
very very sad day for branford and
everybody involved in hockey
canada's best known hockey dad that's a
pretty good legacy
for any father erik sorensen global news
toronto walter gretzky was the son of
immigrants his parents started a
vegetable farm in 1932 in canning
ontario where he was born and raised
he was a proud farm kid remembering his
days there
fondly we had the little farm we had
cows four cows without my mother milked
every morning and they put the milk out
on the road
we had one horse my dad used to plow the
fields with the one horse and one
one plow and we grew cucumbers we'd pick
cucumbers all summer long
he was also a devoted employee of bell
canada working as an installer and
repairman for 34 years before retiring
in 1991.
in 2007 walter gretzky was named to the
order of canada for his contributions to
minor hockey
and his dedication to charities that is
global national for this friday i'm
donna friesen
tonight in his hometown walter gretzky
is being remembered people are paying
their respects laying flowers at a
statue of wayne
and his parents it's meant to celebrate
not just wayne's accomplishments
but the family's contributions to the
community and to hockey
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye
you